the elections Rosanne we are in the
craziest time that I ever remember in
America right now yes [ __ ] PT Barnum
on [ __ ] drugs that's what it feels
like yeah it's awesome yeah you love it
I love every [ __ ] second of it yeah I
can never sleep I'm up like I can't stop
reading it's so fascinating seeing what
they're doing to us all you know they're
really trying to factional eyes that's
their trinity - they're trying to divide
us on every single non-issue they can
dream up you don't like Hillary I know
that much right you're not a Hillary
like her I've met and had dinner and
lunch with her I've spoken to her about
women's issues and Jewish issues and
things like that and charities and how I
I don't think that charities should you
know I do think charity should be above
being taxed mm-hmm
but by god they shouldn't have a [ __ ]
banks worth of money if they're trying
to help people right they shouldn't be
buying [ __ ] property and Dubai right
say about a profit-making charity that
right there I start I start seeing the
duality of everything I mean before that
yeah I saw just a double [ __ ] my double
mind [ __ ] a double double talking Big
Brother mind [ __ ] where the rich is
getting way richer anybody who's
contaminated with money is a filthy
dirty [ __ ] rat and that's the bottom
line
capitalism is in it's on its deathbed so
what do you think is the better option
because I want to talk about the movie a
little bit and you talk about sort of
socialism but not not sort of watching
or socially sit just stoplights streets
and I believe healthcare you pay your
taxes to get something you pay your
taxes and as I say search exoteric lis
in my movie in a decent socialist
structure one receives healthcare or
something for their taxes schools then
they don't turn around pay their checks
and then
for schools - mm-hmm this is national
socialism and that's I don't like that
one that's not a good system because
it's based on vampire capitalism and
that's what's dying it should die and
people should take a deep [ __ ] breath
tighten that belt take a step back and
let it go stop trying to prop it up it's
supposed to die cuz it doesn't work yeah
it's evil so you're not talking about
capitalism just capitalism you're
talking about this crony capitalism and
the way they've rigged everything see
they said they say and do the opposite
of what they when they say free markets
they don't mean free markets they mean
free markets for slavers now that's a
fixed and rigged [ __ ] system against
most people so as that's what that's
what's going on here right it's sort of
like the internet made people wake up to
some level of reality that the media is
kind of in it with I think some people I
think I mean I see what people are
saying to me
like people are waking up to just how
rigged the system is how everyone is
being pitted the media pits everybody
against everybody I mean turn on the TV
right now what's going on with black
lives matter that's what I wanted that's
why I ran for president oh I I made the
movie and I think my movie
Roseanne for president which is out now
yeah it it shows where I planted the
season I knew right where to plant him
so I mean I feel just so vindicated and
I feel really powerful like jeez I did I
did find bright words and I always will
try to find right words the good thing
about right words is they turn off
idiots and then we don't need any of
them the less of them interpreting and
mansplaining and [ __ ] go explaining
and Empire's feral splaining are [ __ ]
when it is about profit sharing it's
that [ __ ] simple you have to pay
people decently for working and every
problem on earth disappears then what
the minute that happens because they
only have wars for slavery that's why
they have worse so they can have slate
slave labor so they have the [ __ ] war
well
the less we would war the more money for
us that's that's what I'm saying
mm-hmm it's not dude that just this one
time let's instead step back let it fall
learn how to grow our own food this is
number one mm-hmm food is money and
getting our water harvesting our you
know surviving we've got a step back
from the [ __ ] it doesn't matter
which one of them wins it's the same
[ __ ] it's a doo-wop allistic
fundraising arm of the prison
military-industrial complex and you know
brags it to me was [ __ ] the heroes
that was the heroes cry the rebel yell I
love it yeah cuz we don't I thought we
didn't want this one world government
and we're back in the 90s remember they
were just with the one world [ __ ]
evil and you loominatee they were
working up some back [ __ ] right
which I went right in the heart of that
too and I'm like I know what you're
doing and when you tell people you know
what they're doing it explodes them so
what do you make of the whole black
lives matter thing cuz this is this is
it I mean I feel like this is going to
be the issue until the election and
probably much much longer than that
well I have black teenage males in my
family it's very frightening and it you
know it's you know that's not like
they're making it up it's true and real
you know it happens too often it happens
to Hispanics a lot here too but they
don't report it as much mm-hmm and
they're also locked up hand over fist
but it's just you know it's the news
again wagging the dog
yeah so the news basically wants us all
to hate each other right like it's just
about good stories that interest us
that's all it's it's speaking to the
demographic that it wants to fleece yeah
hello capitalism yeah so what [ __ ]
how do we get some smart people to you
don't it's me that's it that's all there
[ __ ] is that's it and I'm so tired of
people not seeing
but you know I've gone crazy over it for
quite a while been like well you know
and you know as a Jew I believe that
everything does happen for the good is
that a Jew thought that they end up well
because the history of the Jews a lot of
bad stuff happened it's been a sort of a
one endless bad thing after another all
along you know to be like we've been
removing Holocaust it and some other
stuff
yes so where so how does it get to the
good part just this once we will do the
right thing just this one time please
that's why my prayer is just this one
time we would don't less that he's
[ __ ] paid left us fake left [ __ ]
they're full of [ __ ] [ __ ] they're
anti-union so you call me I think we can
put the PAL back in Palestine
Palestinian yeah cuz you know to me as
an old socialist and so where my
grandfather's grandmother's they were
the [ __ ] [ __ ] that thought this [ __ ]
up
they weren't greedy pigs and they didn't
want to kill people
mm-hmm they just want a profit-sharing
want to be paid fairly for their labor
and I think that that's the only real
issue on earth and everything is a labor
issue that can easily be solved if you
take all the drama and [ __ ] out of
it and it could be easily [ __ ] fixed
and then we would so evolved to such a
[ __ ] different place and I think we're
going there our technology proves that
we're going there and at the top of
those pyramids where those programmers
sit there's a lot of really moral people
more and more because I think that you
at some point I say after that dark
night of the soul that we all have rich
poorer will any color whatever every
culture you've got to make the decision
to look yourself in the face in the
mirror
and some people they don't have no
reflection mmm and no self-reflection
means they're not they're not really a
person they're not really a human so
basically being present I think what
you're saying sort of being present in
your own welfare that being aware is
really so hard it's hard but it's really
the most human thing you can do right
because that's how you don't get
manipulated by all these people that are
trying to split us all the time you can
do this then then you can avoid that
yeah evil isn't really a person although
there are people who follow evil mm-hmm
but evil itself is it's a thought so
it's easy to turn it off
yeah and it shouldn't be turned off yeah
that's why I always talk about ideas on
this show because I believe that good
ideas will always be bad ideas if you
let them be spoke of where now yeah what
kind of crazy [ __ ] yeah that was crazy
yeah after what I've listened to for 20
minutes that's crazy
explain that good ideas that if that we
have to have free speech and let
everyone say whatever they done that can
be read on real freedom that real
freedom we'll probably yeah because
freedom only works for good it never
works for bad and I mean there's a very
good oh yeah freedom always works for
unity profit sharing justice for women
and children right nobody ever said I'm
too free right no Society was ever well
why did they crumble well they were too
free that never had well say that [ __ ]
right I understand what they're saying
cuz you can't let it be free for slavers
you can't let it be free for evildoers
they they take away everybody else
freedom you got to be for freedom and
sometimes what you're gonna do to defend
against those who don't want you to have
freedom therein lies in the flesh
there's the [ __ ] right right that's
where the rubber meets the road right
mm-hmm so you were always into all this
right
you were always yes because thinking
about it I mean the show Roseanne you
know buddy did what you did you took a
family that was struggling at almost
every episode
some struggle clear I'm in harness
he him and jackie gleason and um even
Red Skelton and Lucy I mean everybody
you didn't know
Lucy was rich or nothing when she was
just in that one room right but you did
it I guess at a time when maybe sitcoms
there was a road paved for me I didn't
just come out of nowhere there was a
road paved for me right I guess maybe
what I meant is that you did it at a
time when I think we're Goldberg was
that my Goldberg that's all it's a
remake now but I isn't even a remake
this is the Goldberg's now have
something to do with that
Goldberg show that's right but I guess
what I meant is that your show came on
when when Cosby showed a very middle up
you know sort of middle class or he
almost upper middle class black family
which was really interesting and
groundbreaking and then you came in and
said here's what middle America the part
that everyone forgets la doesn't care
about them New York mocks them whatever
it is you came in and said this is what
I'm gonna do and the jokes were real
everything about it the fights that you
and and Dan had they were that you and
John Goodman had I mean everything it
was real so you always did you always
realize that that was what that way you
wanted to do yeah that was my goal like
[ __ ] them [ __ ] I'll show them
yeah and I knew why they were doing it
too and it was a a real woman shaming
thing and I didn't like that well what
was women Jamie television and it pissed
me off sorry I go [ __ ] you know I'm
gonna get in there and do this and it
just started forming you know how an
idea comes and then you know the jokes
came it's always about the jokes of
course yeah I was always just looking
for a place to put my German I just love
jokes yeah I loved they just come to me
how i speaking jokes on so I'm a comic
you know yeah but no there's a lot of
thought in comedy in comics we're smart
we need more good comedy now don't you
think like we feel like we don't like I
every morning I wake up and I see
something the news and I'm like
if only George Carlin was around for
this you know I gotta give it up to Doug
Stanhope and I do think he's this this
day and age one a George Carlin types or
children or whatever you call it you
know HOF Springs or whatever yeah but I
have to say that I went down to met
seashores The Comedy Store there MIT's
he gave us all our starts yeah Thank You
Mitzi and Tuesday night is my camp men
are the names I remember anything that's
all black comics mm-hmm oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
out of hair I've seen anything like it
yeah they're mixed-media they're doing
with mixed-media it's genius I could and
they let me come come up and dance but
oh there's some genius comics on Tuesday
night main room Comedy Store movie star
level brilliant physical as well you
know the we used to have those different
comics we'd have like a physical guy a
guy did characters a guy who sang and
did impressions mm-hmm these are all
that with one yeah it's scary genius
Wow and I love seeing scary genius
comedy and I've seen a lot of it you
know it's out there it's coming you know
if Trump wins is a good only good part
really is it's gonna be so great for
comedy I mean oh my god the jokes will
just [ __ ] write the jokes it'll be
great for us but not great for the
country probably no I think it
laughing's good for the country but yeah
if Hillary gets in it'll be like I'm a
fan yeah
so if Hillary that's that's my thing
right now we're all me I don't know any
[ __ ] jokes I don't know what I'm
gonna do we don't have no Obama jokes
yeah you tell me I mean nobody did
people whisper oh bomber jokes yeah but
a few of them are funny they're just
stereotypes but some of them are funny
yeah so Milo who we've talked about he's
got some funny well well he told me that
night I get this part of why he's
supporting Trump he told me that that
this election has nothing to do with
politics it's purely on culture it's on
this plane man it's basically that's
what he says he'll yeah he's trying they
got hit they got into him
the CIA and the FBI and you know the
Federal Reserve they gotta do everything
they can to make Hillary look good to us
they're going do something they're going
to some extremes
so you think Trump's a very good you
think too many fun not goods around her
she should shred him but she doesn't she
doesn't shed any bad so that's scary but
it just stood there yeah Pfizer and I'd
be like [ __ ] I did sane I'm not gonna
take a dime from you a [ __ ] got
my own my own need your [ __ ] so you kind
of did this it was like what I paid for
it when I was Trump you know when he was
running in the primaries I could sail he
see he was stealing my [ __ ] right and
left so was Bernie Hillary started
stealing my [ __ ] on my show this one
reporter from France came over and she
interviewed me for some big intellectual
[ __ ] that only Jesuits really know
and she said would there be Hillary
Clinton without Roseanne Connor I said
absolutely not there wouldn't be a Sarah
Palin either without Roseanne Connor
I'm not saying Roseanne Barr except for
you know I did animate that character
but that carriers got a life of its own
it's my Frankenstein so how do we keep
pushing out good stuff how do you get
good that's what I'm trying to do is get
some good stuff through the noise and
it's tough but people want it because I
see it every day people are gone
wow-whee needs people want to be smart
and yet the system is designed to make
them dumb mm-hmm so how do you fight
through that well you have to meditate
and you have to find the silence inside
that can combat [ __ ] you know like
like super lady superwoman yeah
bracelets uh you have to find the calm
place in your mentality to just sit and
behold be aware be aware and be hold and
do nothing
just be aware and you can do it by you
know three steps breathing in holding
the breath and
exhaling them breath you know that used
to be called count to ten but it is kind
of counting to ten but afterward when
you do it you have some peace in your
mind when you don't contain any
programming or [ __ ] you're just open
and you feel rather than think and you
feel breath in your body right after
that you can see a lot clearer that's a
good thing to think about rather than
Hillary and Trump yeah be in your body
and be aware of your body of the food
you grow and the excess of the food for
a profit-sharing because you might have
to share your profit with your neighbors
in order for them to bard or something
of equal value to you because you're
gonna probably be without money so these
are real things they're not [ __ ]
things money's papers [ __ ] that
doesn't exist anymore it's not backed up
by anything just paper yeah why do you
work so hard to get paper for food
shelter clothing and community and
safety well you already got that [ __ ] if
you work it it's right in front of you
like cows are in a pasture full of food
we got that's how the world really is
when you don't have money Oh [ __ ]
there anyway you don't need paper grow a
tomato right don't need to work people
should be working four to six hours a
week
you